بحر اليابان مسرح توتر جديد بين موسكو
وطوكيو باعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اختبار اسطولها البحري في المحيط الهادئ
لصاروخ كروز فرد صوتي مضاد للسفن من طرز
موسكيت يمكن ان يشكل تهديدا للقطع البحريه
الكبيره
اوضحت الوزاره ان الصاروخ موسكيت متوسط
المدى تمكن من ضرب هدف وهمي من مسافه تقدر
بنحو 100 كيلومتر ويمكنه تدمير سفينه على
بعد 120 كيلومترا وجاءت التجربه بعد اسبوع
من تحليق قاذفتين استراتيجيتين روسيتين
قادرتين على حمل رؤوس النوويه فوق بحر
اليابان وذلك لاكثر من سبع ساعات رافقتها
مقاتله حربيه خطوه اذنتها اليابان وقالت
انها ستظل يقظه حيله تحركات موسكو وكانت
تعهدت لكيف بالدعم خلال زياره رئيس
وزرائها بعد ان رفعت ميزانيه دفاعها وغيرت
من عقيدتها الدفاعيه في البحر ذاته تستعرض
كوريا الشماليه عضلاتها زعيمها كيم جونغ
اون سرع من وتيره استعدادات بلاده في مجال
استخدام اسلحه نوويه كقوه ردع في وجه ما
سماها القوه النوويه المتفوقه التي تتجاوز
الخيال
كشفت لاول مره عن راس حربي نووي تكتيكي في
استعراض واضح على انه يمكنها وضع مثل هذه
الرؤوس الحربيه على قاذفات الصواريخ
متعدده كبيره الحجم او صواريخ كروز تجربه
تاتي مع تسارع المناورات الجويه والبحريه
والتجارب الصاروخيه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه من جهه وكوريا الشماليه
من جهه اخرى
فحامله الطائره الامريكيه يو اس اس التي
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وصلت الى قاعده
بوسان البحريه بكوريا الجنوبيه وعلى متنها
اكثر من 80 مقاتله حربيه لتنفيذ مناورات
مع السفن حربيه كوريه جنوبيه
اتساع دائره استعراض القدرات جعلت رئيس
الوزراء الياباني يحذر من ان شرق اسيا قد
يكون اوكرانيا التاليه فموسكو نشرت صواريخ
دفاعيه ساحليه من طراز باستيون في جزر
الكوريل المتنازع عليها مع اليابان وقد
تضاعف نشر محطات رادار لانظمه الانذار
بالهجوم الصاروخي قرب الجزر لتغطيه جميع
مناطق بحر اليابان وتوفير حمايه للاسطول
الروسي في المحيط الهادئ التحركات
الامريكيه تاتي ايضا بينما تحول بحر جنوب
الصين الى ساحه مواجهه حيث تتبادل واشنطن
وبيجين الاتهامات وتتنازع الصين مع
الفلبين وماليزيا وفيتنام وتايوان السياده
في هذه المنطقه وبينما اجرت روسيا والصين
مناورات مشتركه نهايه العام الماضي في بحر
جنوب الصين اعلنت بيجين ابعاد المدمره
الامريكيه يو اس اس ميليوس بعد ان دخلت
البحر مما يعكس حاله التوتر في هذه
المنطقه